service que reste t il
nous sommes surpris tu manges tu as ils
font des menus que pour les chiites a
l'air en forme ça fait plaisir
cet amant vert ici
elle a disparu comment c'est possible
que je sois parti comme ça vous ne
surveillez pas il pas une prison ici
n'est sûr non mais attendez c'est déjà
arrivé quelques fois mais enfin bon
c'est rare c'est ma première fois en
c'est une vraie passoire humain peut pas
lancer un avis de recherche
la télé ils passent leur temps avec leur
alerte enlèvement on va faire pareil
première question est ce que votre mère
avec majeur j'étais hartl on voit tout
nous ici john je suis tu as déjà vu cela
doit [ __ ] de cartes postales de ma
grand mère
voilà sortir il faut que tu mets une
enquête les suisses voix voulez-vous
souci des choses qu'on a quand même le
meilleur spot pour ça ici alors écoutez
moi je veux pas m'immiscer dans votre
vie privée mais moi en tant que
professionnel je suis obligé de vous
prévenir ronge la falaise comme ça
attaque on arrive ici on saute on est
venu pour ça
sauf que en cas de vent retour en
arrière parce qu'on ne pas me suicider
en fait juste quelqu'un qui aime la vie
ah bah il faudrait le dire à votre
visage alors parce que là on peut pas
deviner
jean plus connaissez tout pour moi
quand
des tracteurs ta mère
c'est bien genre à partir comme ça
c
la patagonie